baby
mama well that's
loyalty it sounds like if if he's
anybody he should be the mother of his
child no am I crazy for this one it kind
of sounds like you breaking up a
[Applause]
family he's still in his house with his
wife and his
baby what's the
problem doesn't with her no he said he
don't but he I think he lying yes he's
lying that's what we call a BL and
lot I mean maybe he should be he
shouldn't be dating you on the side if
he is actually interested in her I will
say that my best advice would be to
either I'd say break up with him or also
get
pregnant play this game okay yeah that
that bit was good he's right also like
his his reaction is Tethered to reality